what is hmm what are you thinking about  it's a lot of work for us to do in two  days they're both full days why do we  only have two days we're in stages why  do you why do we have to do it in two  days why I'll tell you in terms of  Beverly her availability we have her for  these two days and that's it well I know  but the thing is like you know we we're  not on location where we have to you  know that we aren't we own the stages  you know it just drives me nuts that we  have to do two days if somebody  arbitrarily says you've got to do it in  two days no that [ __ ] really pisses  me off this is absolutely horrible we  never get any extra shots we never get  any time to experiment we never get to  you know go dreamy or anything we barely  [ __ ] make our days I could have spent  a week in the fireman's I love that  place and dream up all kinds of stuff  you know that this is sick this kind of  [ __ ] way to do it you don't get a  chance to sink into anything it's not a  way to work